[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le mont royal reste la seule montagne
sur l'île de montréal donc si on cherche
du dénivelé
si on veut c'est l'endroit où on va
aller si on a un vélo de montagne et
qu'on n'a pas de moyens de sortir de
l'île de montréal
ça reste la seule c'est le seul endroit
où on nous comptons bien qu'on a du
plaisir pour pratiquer ce sport là la
plupart des réseaux de sentiers de vélo
de montagne sont fermés présentement il
reste à nice distancé dabou on
n'encourage pas les gens à aller donc on
se rabat sur ce qui est disponible
malheureusement ce qui est disponible
par ménage et pour supporter la pratique
si on a décidé de réserver un niveau
comme celui là est de le conserver
l'usagé qu'on en fait à laisser aller
une perturbation comme celle-là de vélo
de montagne ne me semble pas du tout
compatible avec l'idée de préservation
d'un milieu naturel
un endroit tranquille le port un renard
et il faut qu'ils cherchent longtemps
sur la montagne
il ya des sentiers partout quand on
parle du sommet du parc en fête pour les
cyclistes qui se sont créés un circuit
qui descend ici jusqu'à minuit et une
ensuite il remonte le long de la clôture
du cimetière mont-royal puis là ils ont
accès aux sonnets d'autres noms en
allant sur la gauche à travers le
cimetière ou à la partie du parc et le
long du bord mont royal
puis pour redescendre dans une zone
aussi où il ya un peu moins de man fait
que oui c'est pour l'is crise c'est un
très beau circuit ya une créature qui
s'installe de les ré ouverte par des
usagers qui veulent pas assez là on crée
des conditions difficiles pour des pour
des végétaux c'est des êtres vivants
l'on réalise pas que quand on pile là
dessus d'un être vivant et donc on
réduit sa capacité à se régénérer et on
va favoriser d'autres espèces qui sont
qui sont tolérantes et puis on va
simplifier la flore beaucoup alors que
c'est la diversité qui rend ces milieux
là les plus solides de voir le mil les
sentiers s'élargir s'éroder
voir les seules la montagne de plus en
plus dégradées puis même s'inquiéter
pour l'avenir de la forêt parce que
lorsqu'on a de moins en moins de sol en
dessous des arbres mais il y en a moins
de moins en moins de petits qui repousse
donc senna c'est l'avenir notre oreille
qui est hypothéquée
et pas de lui offrir une pratique pour
les montagnes sur les de mourir donc le
statut courrier pas acceptable parce
qu'un statu quo contribuer aux dommages
c'est à dire que présentement puis c'est
vrai pour le vélo montagne c'est vrai
pour la course en sentiers ou un paquet
d'autres activités il ya des sentiers
qui sont pas des sentiers en réalité qui
sont pas faits pour supporter ces usages
le et si on laisse les gens présents
dans ses allées dedans parce que
multitude de raisons on contribue plus à
la protection de montagne ça c'est
certain
puis on vous parle a perdu évidemment le
problème s'est amplifiée ben je pense ça
prendrait une volonté commune de
l'ensemble des acteurs que ce soit le
service de police de la ville de
montréal la ville de montréal les
organismes de sensibilisation comme les
amis de la montagne qu'on travaille
vraiment tous ensemble dire mais là on
va agir pour passer le message pour
intervenir pour réduire cette pratique
la solution mais il faut être prétendant
discuter qu'il ya des solutions qui sont
plus compliquées